well Christmas has it's always been far
back as I can remember my favorite
holiday actually holidays don't mean
anything to me except Christmas now the
the thing is though that every Christmas
that I can remember has has been really
cruddy and in fact it has seemed to me
that each Christmas is worse than the
one before and sometimes that's my own
doing i'm the author of the ruin but at
other times it has seemed that Christmas
itself hates me so the book is a is a
compilation of not not all but a few of
these holidays and the thing that I have
found is that no matter how nasty the
Christmas was there's always been
usually in retrospect always been
something perfect and small and shiny
hidden within it and that has made me
appreciate the holiday even more
I don't have a sense of that I suppose
it is for me more of a state of mind
we'll probably in front my laptop
computer actually wherever that is I
don't have home as a place in the chest
that many people have home is like a how
many ribs do we have what 15 12 it's the
extra rib home at home is the four
people it's the like a Hammett but I've
actually never had that I have um I've
tried to uh to create that as a
structure which is actually the last
story in this book and that structure
flooded so for me it's really more of
its more about being finding being where
I want to be with people I care about
um well it depends I suppose on who you
ask and how you define gift from my
perspective I could continue to write
memoirs probably for many many many
years I don't want to rest of my life
but many years however I could never do
that because I it's just not interesting
to me at a certain point it um but it
but but I mean it's uh it's certainly
you know the material is there what I
have found is yes I've definitely had
some unusual circumstances in my life
but I've also just paid attention do I
pay attention to what happens to me and
but I pay a law very close attention i
fixate I focus and I'm a visual thinker
I don't um and a lot of people are
visual thinkers and and analog they kind
of flopped back and forth but I'm only
visual only like if you hand me a
shopping list for a split second I'm
going to see the hieroglyphics that are
there you know and when I am writing
anything a memoir or a novel or whatever
I'm trans I'm translating these images
so there's I suppose there's a limit to
how much time I want to look at at
myself you know and what at the past
self I'll always write about what's
going on in my life and the reason for
that
is um it's not actually because I'm so
fascinated with myself it's because I
can't think um you know I can't think
like have thoughts in my head you know
like juggling them up there and think
them through and come to a conclusion
it's like math for me I can't do that I
I have to I have to sort of you know in
a way I have to storyboard my
circumstances at any given moment and in
order to see them and appreciate them
and I appreciate them that's probably
the wrong word in order to understand
them so I'll always right because it's
um I'm now at this point I'm kind of
trained to a to think that way but I um
I like many other things many other
topics